يستعرض ابرز المواقع الاخرى التي تعرضت
لقصف في اوكرانيا خلال الساعات الماضيه
حيث تركزت الهجمات على مناطق دينيبرو ومدن
الشرق وخركيز ففي مقاطعه ذابولوجيا استهدف
قصف روسي كثيف مناطق واسعه وقالت السلطات
الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه ان الروس شنوا 100
غاره على سبعه عشره بلده ما تسبب باضرار
في المناطق الماهوله وشبكات البنيه
التحتيه في ميكولايف تركز القصف الروسي
على المناطق الساحليه والتجمعات المائيه
حسب عمده المدينه وادى الى تضرر العديد من
منازل المدنيين وايضا الممتلكات الخاصه
والعامه
اما في خيرسون فتكثف القصف الروسي على قلب
المدينه والعديد من القرى الواقعه على خط
التماس بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
حسب حاكم المقاطعه الاوكراني وايضا على
مشارف مدينه خان كيف كما نتابع اصابع
القصف مستودعا للنفط مرتين وقال مكتب
الرئيس الاوكراني ان معدات لضخ المنتجات
النفطيه تضررت جراء ذلك